et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
Claude Guibal grand reporter à la
rédaction internationale de Radio France
bonjour Claude bonjour face à vous Bilal
tarabes chroniqueur international ici
même à France 24 bonjour Bilal bonjour
Raphaël le mouvement de protestation se
poursuit en Iran et d'une certaine
manière se durcit avec la grève générale
lancée aujourd'hui pour 3 jours la
difficile dans mesurer l'ampleur dans un
pays où tous les médias sont sous
contrôle mais des vidéos tournaient sur
le net notamment à des vitrines de
magasins fermées à Téhéran et d'autres
grandes villes notamment carragispan
machad Fabrice ou encore Chiraz le signe
Claude Guilbert que l'annonce hier par
le procureur général hirondins de
l'abolition de la police des mœurs pour
l'heure en tout cas ne semble pas
entamée la détermination des
manifestants en tout cas il semble que
les manifestants et bien compris qu'il
s'agit là plutôt d'une manœuvre
dilatoire un petit peu pour justement
détourner l'attention de ces trois jours
de grève qui devraient culminer mercredi
par la journée de l'étudiant ou la
mobilisation est annoncé comme très
importante cette annonce en plus je
pense que ce qui ressort de ce qui est
dit sur les réseaux sociaux en Iran
c'est que tout le monde a compris la
limite de cette annonce qui a été faite
par le procureur général mais qui n'a
pas été confirmé plus officiellement
elle est très ambiguë on parle voilà de
la suspension de la police des mœurs
mais en soi la loi qui concerne
l'obligation de port du voile elle
existe toujours et une femme iranienne
qui serait arrêté sans porter le voile
et toujours soumise à cette loi une
arrestation 72 coups de fouet et rien
n'empêche quasiment consubstantiel en
fait
depuis
cette obligation elle existe depuis 79
elle a été confirmée enfin légalisé même
en sous forme de loi dans les années 80
et quoi qu'il en soit le régime iranien
aujourd'hui tout à fait encore les
moyens de faire appliquer cette loi
d'une façon de la façon quand il dont il
le souhaite en punissant comme ça a été
le cas encore aujourd'hui le directeur
d'un parc d'attraction ou des femmes
sans voile ont été prises en photo Bilal
jusqu'à présent pas de confirmation
parce que c'est vrai que ça déclaration
elle date de ce weekend et elle a
évidemment beaucoup fait réagir on
s'attendait d'ailleurs éventuellement à
ce que derrière le régime iranien en
braille pour leur Ryan tel c'est toi qui
qui impose encore le port du voile elle
est bien en vigueur tout comme
d'ailleurs la police qui est chargée de
l'appliquer c'est effectivement non pas
un procureur général mais bien au
ministre de l'intérieur c'est à dire au
gouvernement et au Parlement dans
décidément il y a deux choses là-dedans
c'est comme comme la Rapée Claude
effectivement ça a été donc
techniquement le port du voile a été
légalisé en 83 par un vote du Parlement
et la logique veut que ce soit le même
Parlement qui vote son abolition sa
modification etc sauf que déjà à ce
stade il faut rappeler qu'on est en
république Islam qui diront et donc
comme le dit son nom c'est un système
politique particulier qui a été inventé
et mis en place par layatollah romainini
en 79 qui s'appelle villa el fakir si on
le traduit c'est le gouvernement du
docks en résumé ça veut dire que les
religieux supervisent le corps élu on
ira il y a deux il y a deux états un
petit peu parallèles donc de toute façon
le Parlement ne fera rien si la yatollah
actuel ramène ou le Conseil des des
gardiens et des religieux n'est pas
d'accord ça c'est la première chose
ensuite sur la police des mœurs
elle-même faut quand même rappeler
qu'elle ne date que entre guillemets de
2005-2006 c'est-à-dire du populiste et
ultra conservateur ancien président
Mahmoud ahmady nedjad qui l'a mis en
place uniquement dans les grandes villes
en Iran donc il se parlent à brise
Shiraz Téhéran etc pour faire peu
plaisir à son électorat conservateur et
aussi au mot là en affichant dans les de
rue voilà quelque chose qui dirait vous
voyez je fais appliquer la charia et les
mœurs mais avant ça entre 83 et 2005 il
y avait bien d'autres polices qui
faisaient respecter la charia et les
mœurs c'est ses lois il y avait les
comités de la révolution au début des
années 80 donc d'ailleurs Marjane
satrapie parle dans père et police on a
les bassidy occasionnellement enfin il y
a tout un tas de corps de police qui
faisaient respecter ça avant la police
des mœurs et qui peut-être les front
respectés après en cas de dissolution ça
peut être simplement un changement de
nom ou d'organes en tout cas beaucoup de
manifestants qui s'expriment sur les
réseaux sociaux attendent davantage du
pouvoir désormais à l'image de cette
vendeuse écoutez là d'un magasin de
chaussures de la province du Kurdistan
le régime iranien c'est très bien qu'il
vit ces derniers jours et qu'il est sur
le point de tomber il fait tout ce qu'il
peut pour survivre plus longtemps et
c'est très bien que si l'obligation du
port du voile suiviste il est voué à
disparaître cette décision vise à
influencer l'opinion publique
alors là c'est la première conséquence
orale jusqu'à présent d'un dirigeant du
régime en tout cas la représentante ce
régime Claude le pouvoir peut-il être
tenté de céder en partie à la rue si la
grève se prolongeait ce qu'on voit là
c'est une commerçante qui s'exprime mais
en tout cas ce que dit cette femme c'est
que tout cela ne va pas les empêcher de
continuer parce que évidemment à travers
le port du voile qui n'est fait pas
partie des revendications en fait
première des Iraniens dans la rue même
si c'est la mort de Marsa mini qui a été
battue pour en avoir pas porté le voile
le voile est quelque chose de symbolique
et quand je dis symbolique c'est pas
dans le dans le sens c'est pas négatif
mais symbolique dans le sens où à
travers ce voile c'est toute tous les
fondements du régime islamique depuis
1979 qui tiennent là-dessus c'est un des
piliers un des derniers marqueurs
visibles d'ailleurs du pouvoir du
pouvoir théocratique et à travers cela
ce que à travers tout ce qu'on a entendu
dans les manifestations depuis des
semaines des mois maintenant ce que
réclame les gens c'est la fin de ce
régime islamique iranien et ce qui est
très important je trouve à souligner
c'est que
l'ensemble des manifestants sont tous
des enfants de ce régime de cette
République islamique d'Iran c'est pas
des gens qui sont nés sous le chat ou
quoi que ce soit ce sont des gens qui
sont issus de ce système qui ont été à
l'école de la République islamique
d'Iran et qui aujourd'hui n'en peuvent
plus quand ils vont dans les rues ils
savent ce qu'ils risquent ils risquent
des peines de mort comme celles qui ont
été appliquées ces derniers jours et sur
lequel le gouvernement essaie aussi de
de de
distraire l'attention d'exécution depuis
le début de l'année c'est un
records s'arrêter ils veulent le la
machine répressive est en route mais on
sent aussi qu'à l'intérieur de
[Musique]
qui n'ont pas connu d'autres pouvoirs et
qui aujourd'hui manifestent sans leader
et sans coordination apparente est-ce
une force ou une faiblesse c'est-à-dire
combien de temps ce mouvement va-t-il
pouvoir durer sous cette forme et est-ce
qu'il va pouvoir prendre de l'ampleur
sans l'émergence en tout cas de de
figure pour le représenter vous avez lu
dans mes pensées parce que j'allais vous
parler de l'exemple à algérien mais on
pourrait parler de l'exemple irakien de
l'exemple libanais de ces dernières
années alors là à court terme sur ce
qu'on voit maintenant sur ce qu'on voit
depuis mi-septembre fin septembre oui
c'est une force pourquoi parce que bien
finalement ce mouvement protéiforme
permet de diminuer si vous voulez le le
la latitude répressive du régime en gros
c'est des petits groupes qui sortent à
droite à gauche dans des petites villes
c'est pas prévu difficile à anticiper
donc difficile à réprimer donc ça pour
l'instant on peut considérer que c'est
une force en revanche à moyen terme et à
plus long terme
un petit peu moins parce que d'abord il
y a tout un pan de la population qui
attend qu'on lui présente un plan B qui
pourrait ou qui voudrait bien basculer
dans la contestation du régime mais qui
aimerait bien qu'on lui propose une
alternative et ça pour l'instant ça
manque première chose et ensuite
deuxième chose il y a les fritements
tout simplement de la mobilisation et
c'est là qu'on peut mettre sur la table
l'exemple algérien irakien ou libanais
c'est-à-dire que sous les coups de
boutoir d'une crise d'une conjoncture
mondiale d'un éventuel covid 23 ou
et de la répression dans les pays
concernés bien finalement de moins en
moins de gens descendraient dans la rue
avec le temps etc jusqu'à ce que la
jusqu'à ce que la mobilisation
meurt meurt d'elle-même on a vu au
Venezuela que même avec un leader
parfois une révolte aussi c'est un
d'elle-même Claude ça enfin en tout cas
ça complique la lecture de ce mouvement
parce que faut d'image évidemment
quotidienne de Lyon on a du mal à se
représenter exact de ce mouvement
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile
effectivement dans la mesure où on ne
peut pas les faire de reportage sur
place ou les informations qui
parviennent sont celles qui parviennent
via les réseaux sociaux et heureusement
qu'elle parviennent c'est comme cela que
l'on sait que la mobilisation va bien
au-delà de Téhéran qu'elle est dans
toutes les villes d'Iran on voit ces
images de de commerce qui ont fermé leur
qui ont tombé leur rideau etc ce qui
nous permet d'avoir une petite idée
effectivement comme on le comme on le
voit là de de du suivi de cette de cette
grève générale parce que il y a en Iran
que les agences d'information
officielles qui elles
j'allais dire propage la doxa la doxa du
gouvernement que la situation est sous
contrôle que les grèves ne sont pas très
suivies et que finalement voilà faisons
rentrer dans l'ordre reste cette
répression que vous évoquiez qui a fait
au moins 300 morts de la veuve même des
autorités donc c'est un chiffre au moins
celui-là qui est les stables incontesté
14000 personnes emprisonnées Bilal c'est
une fuite en avant est-ce qu'un régime
après cela peut encore se réformer ou
est-ce que ça n'annonce qu'une
répression plus féroce
très honnêtement n'en sait rien parce
que justement un régime comme celui-là
par essence il est imprévisible je vais
vraiment schématiser ce que je dis mais
malheureusement on peut très bien voir
un admen à l'iranienne c'est à dire un
jour où toute l'armée alors dans ce cas
là ce serait plutôt les Gardiens de la
révolution donc l'armée parallèle qui
est tenu par les par les religieux mais
bon descendrai dans la rue ferait
dizaines centaines voire milliers de
victimes en un seul jour et bon là une
certaine nature humaine ferait que tout
le monde s'arrêterait ça peut être une
option 2008 2009 lors des manifestations
ce serait une faction si on peut dire ça
à l'intérieur de la République islamique
d'Iran qui irait en faveur d'une réforme
alors ça ça aurait pu être le cas du
temps des présidents modérés puisqu'il y
en avait des modéré des réformateurs ça
on n'a pas le temps de rentrer là-dedans
mais le schisme la religion Chili permet
ça c'est une religion de de discussion
ou effectivement on peut voter contre
réinterpréter etc donc il y aurait pu
sauf que et bien on le voit d'ailleurs à
chaque élection présidentielle tous les
candidats réformateurs et toute tête en
fait réformatrice et systématiquement
écarté du processus donc ça paraît
compliqué Claude
donner des gages c'est encore possible
pour le pouvoir iranien et de de
se réformer à la marge c'est très
difficile comme vient de le dire Bilal
de pouvoir prophétiser on est
journaliste pas le Prophète ce que ce
que le régime iranien va faire parce que
même le fonctionnement de ce régime nous
est relativement
occupe le le poids des mots là le poids
des politiques et le poids une fois de
plus des passes à RAM qui dépassent tout
ça puisque on est à la fois
on est sur le l'outil répressif et
l'outil économique qui va vouloir qui va
pouvoir faire basculer c'est certain que
c'est que si un des appareils
sécuritaire du pays
décide de faire ce pouvoir réformateur
que quelque chose peut bouger sinon on
voit bien qu'il joue la montre et qu'il
joue sur des fritements et un régime qui
s'effondrerait sous le coup des
sanctions à l'image d'une certaine
manière de l'économie de pénurie de
l'URSS qui a fini par avoir raison du
système ça fait des années que le régime
est sous mis à des sanctions que les
Iraniens et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
dans la rue n'en peuvent plus n'ont pas
accès des soins de santé correct non pas
des Iraniens ont un niveau d'éducation
qui est assez impressionnant remarquable
contourne comme ils le peuvent depuis
des années des conditions de vie des
conditions antidémocratiques terribles
et on voit que ça n'a pas suffi jusqu'à
présent à faire tomber le régime qui
comme toujours quand il y a des embargos
et bien ça se contourne on continue à
vendre du pétrole en faisant du
transbordement blanchissant les voilà et
même régionalement si ça a été quand
même le fait de la décennie 2010 c'est
l'expansion iranienne c'est vraiment
c'est c'est vraiment ce concept ces
unités des Gardiens de la Révolution les
Gardiens de la Révolution pour que les
gens comprennent bien ça n'est pas
l'armée iranienne il y a une armée
iranienne c'est une armée parallèle qui
ne répond qu'à layatollah ramennei et à
son à son conseil religieux si vous
voulez et qui elle effectivement tient
des pas entiers de l'économieienne on
parle de 60 70 % du PIB iranien mais qui
a aussi ses antennes militaires en Irak
on en parle avec les cataibas et au
Liban bien évidemment avec le Hezbollah
libanais donc si vous voulez et jusqu'au
Yémen oui et ça ça fait
pas très bon en maths parfois ça fait
une quarantaine d'années voyez donc ça
fait quasiment deux générations de gens
qui ont un pouvoir territorial et
économique ancré et ça c'est extrêmement
compliqué
à bouger
et la Syrie a effectivement été de cette
influence autre actualité Vladimir
Poutine conduisant lui-même une voiture
sur le pont de Crimée partiellement
détruit en octobre dans des
circonstances encore non élucidées les
images elles tournent en boucle dans les
médias russe pas plus tard il y a une
demi-heure encore un animal nous le
disait depuis Moscou assez coté vous le
voyez sur le siège passager le
vice-Premier ministre marathousing qui
dresse le rapport à au chef du Kremlin
sur la progression des travaux de
réparation du pont Moscou je vous le
rappelle avait attribué sa destruction à
un acte terroriste des Ukrainiens Claude
voilà on voit Poutine finalement en
inspectant les travaux de rénovation
l'occasion de montrer qu'ils gardent la
main sur la situation c'est vraiment de
la propagande type ça c'est de la
propagande type c'est aussi une façon de
voilà de de se montrer sur le terrain où
on ne l'a pas beaucoup vu
contrairement à volody mirzelanski que
l'on voit tout le temps dans les rues se
déplacer etc Vladimir Poutine là on sent
que
il faut qu'il sorte il faut qu'il
fallait dans le combat alors que
volodiaze qui est alerte
c'est un il sort il sort là de sa tour
divorce on sent que on est à un moment
quand même assez clé de ce conflit ou la
Russie
militairement parlant et quand même
extrêmement limité donc on voit que
aujourd'hui parce qu'avec le la nouvelle
les nouveaux largages de bombe massif
qui qui a eu
on voit que l'arme principale maintenant
de la Russie c'est utilisé l'hiver comme
marmot de guerre
et donc de rentrer dans des crimes de
guerre puisque tout ce qui est fait
actuellement en Russie est fait pour
rendre la vie des civils absolument
impossibles en bombardant des
infrastructures civiles en bombardant
tout le système énergétique en empêchant
les le système de courant etc donc de
rendre la vie des Ukrainiens allemands
impossible donc qui n'aurait qu'une
option c'est à dire se rendre ou fuir au
même moment Bilal à Moscou accuse Kiev
alors c'est cameronique de d'avoir
bombardé deux bases aériennes russes
avec des drones c'est-à-dire d'avoir
agressé finalement territorialement la
Russie manière de se poser en victime
agressée ou indirectement aussi de
démontrer quand même la capacité
l'Ukraine quand même à à faire preuve
non seulement de résistance mais même
potentiellement d'offensive dans cette
guerre de toute façon après les les deux
contrevancies du krainiennes de ce
trimestre c'est à dire au nord autour de
harkis et au sud vers Kerson c'est quand
même objectivement très difficile de ne
pas reconnaître y compris pour les
Russes les mérites de l'armée
ukrainienne non c'est pas ça vous le
disiez le pont de Crimée le la
destruction d'une partie du plan de
Crimée a été attribuée aux Ukrainiens on
pourrait parler de de la Russie qui
dénonce des bombardements de villages
frontaliers côté russe il y a le
croiseur Moskova coulait en mer Noire
qui a été attribué par les Russes aux
ukra on a même l'attentat à Moscou qui a
tué la fille du de l'idéologue russe
Alexandre dogging donc non et si vous
voulez la Russie s'oppose en victime la
Russie fait la guerre à l'Ukraine parce
qu'elle se considère victime du régime
nazi ukrainien et des par son allié
l'OTAN et par les Occidentaux donc au
final si vous voulez dans la rhétorique
de Moscou de dire que c'est une victime
ou d'attribuer d'attribuer pardon
Ukrainiens des drones des bombardements
de je ne sais quoi non ça nourrit sa
justifie ses actions les choses dont
Claude Guibal parlait qui sont des
bombardements de civils et parce que la
Russie déclare qu'elle est obligée de
faire ça en réponse aux actions des
Ukrainiens très rapidement la Russie
cherche un prétexte ou bien
indirectement elle donne des armes aussi
en montrant que l'Ukraine m'a fait plus
que résister dans cette guerre
c'est oui les deux à la fois après il
faut pas oublier ce contexte avec les
nouvelles sanctions qui viennent d'être
reposer sur la Russie avec l'embargo sur
le pétrole etc donc on montre les bras
merci les muscles merci beaucoup Claude
Guibal qui était avec nous ce soir on va
plus loin avec Bilal tarabé c'est la fin
on va plus loin